We've updated the rock,
paper, scissors app so that it keeps a
running history of each match you play.
The challenge for
this lesson is to add an additional
view with a table to show the history.
This is one example of how
the completed app could look.
Note that the challenge combines
the material of the past two lessons.
We'll segue to a new view and
the new view will be a table.
Let's take a look at
the code that's been added.
Here you can see that
the RockPaperScissorsViewController
has a new property,
an array named history.
We know that this array is going to be
filled up with results from matches.
Let's find where the matches
are being added.
Here in the throwDown method,
in this line, you can see where
the matches are being added.
The history array will be
the model that drives the table.
The model that determines
the number of rows, etc.
Right now the history
table is kind of bare.
The cells are using the right detail
cell without adding an image.
For the challenge up you're free
to create any cell you want.
You can create images for winning and
losing, different text sizes, fonts.
Go nuts!
If you are interested in adding
your own custom cell views,
in the next section we have a few notes
to steer you in the right direction.